great thank you so much thanks to the
organizers for having me thanks to Hulu
for supporting me being here
my name is Wendy Bruce and I am a data
analyst at Hulu in my day to day job I
help our product and tech teams use user
behavior to inform how they're making
new features and identifying issues that
sort of thing but what I'm going to talk
to you about today is a project that I
did at one of our data team hack days so
this is not what I do in my normal
day-to-day work at Hulu when I first
started at Hulu I was a data analyst on
the team that made our organizational or
operational intelligence tool which
allows you to see what the users are
doing in real time and as part as being
a data analyst on the team that made
that tool one of my roles was to develop
KPIs for for the usage of it and most of
the KPIs were about the WHO and the when
of using the tool none of them were
really getting at the why people were
using the tool and so the purpose of my
talk today is to show you how I mined
JIRA to get an understanding of why
people who are using our tool and
hopefully you guys will feel empowered
to go out and mine your own JIRA systems
to you understand really anything you
want to know about your work and so I'm
just gonna start I'll give you like a
little bit about our operational
intelligence tool it's called glyph so
when I say glyph that's what I'm
referring to then I'll tell you a little
bit about JIRA how many people here use
JIRA perfect I'll tell you very little
bit about JIRA and then I'll show you
how I built a flask out to investigate
glyph usage in JIRA and the goal of this
was to be able to have a dashboard where
I could go and see
Glyph usage in JIRA then I'll go through
some lessons learn and potential future
development if I ever go back to working
on this so our operational intelligence
tool is called glyph if you're not
familiar with the term operational
intelligence it's kind of the idea of
using the current state to look forward
and also understand what's going on
right now versus the comparison would be
like business intelligence was sort of
like a look in the past and so up well
my boss has a slide that has like
operational intelligence is the
windshield of the car and business
intelligence is the rear view mirror so
it's like looking forward versus looking
back and the reason that we say
operational intelligence is that our
data that is in glyph is in real-time so
if I go and do a query I'm getting the
state of our apps at that current time
and we do that by getting events
straight off of our clients so if I'm
watching Hulu on Xbox my Xbox is sending
back what I'm doing on the app if I'm
watching Hulu on my iPhone my iPhone is
sending back what I'm doing on the
iPhone in real time and so using Glyph
our product teams and our tech teams can
look at this real time data to answer a
variety of different kinds of questions
and then the other important fact about
using glyph is that those query results
and reports that are made in the tool
are shareable so I can say look here's
this interesting thing or something
looks weird here and then I can share
that with somebody who also might be
interested in it or might want to fix it
and they will see exactly what I've seen
in real time and so the important
takeaway it's from glyph is that it's
real time data its shareable and it's
used by internal Hulu employees so just
to give you an idea of what glyph looks
like
usage is actually instrumented to be
viewed in glyph so this is a query
looking at glyph usage for the first
half of 2018 aggregated by month
so in glyph we have a few different
types of views so this is a time series
view but there's also like column views
pie charts just tabular views and then
you can specify a time range so a past
day or here I'm doing you know past year
almost and then you for time series you
can pick whatever granularity you want
and then you would just say what event
type you're interested in so since I'm
looking at glyph queries I've selected
the glyph query event but if I was doing
this for actual understanding of our app
behavior I might have something like
start a show or open up the app or
something like that and then I could
track that those numbers in whatever
time range I specified and I can also
filter which cut off here but I can also
filter based on different features so
like if I'm only interested in iPhones
or if I'm only interested in X boxes or
I'm only interested in people who are
watching live TV I can put in those
filters and and get a fairly robust
real-time shareable query until like I
said I was making some glyph usage kpi's
and there's a pretty standard kpi's who
is using glyph how are they using glyph
so either I can make my own query and be
like exploring the data myself or I can
share a query and maybe I'm a glyph user
but I'm only looking at queries that
other people made so those are like
different levels of usage obviously do
people keep using glyph do they come
back month over months and does it work
so these are pretty standard kpi's
and but they really are just like who
and when and I was really interested in
why people are using glyph and so I came
up with a few different ways that we
could sort of understand why people are
using this tool so one is we could
survey the users and we actually do
survey our users a lot we know who our
main stakeholders are but the way we
decide that people are the main
stakeholders is simply by either query
volume so people who are running a lot
of queries or people who are ask us a
lot of questions and so this is going to
give us a really biased view of our
users so either really loud people are
really people that run a lot of queries
versus maybe there's like particular
segments of our user base that we really
want to learn more about so if we can
get out the context of why they're using
our tool then maybe we could adjust the
feature development within cliff we
could do some natural language
processing on the name so you would name
your query can you hear me so okay so
you would name your query and and
depending on what words you use we might
be able to understand a little bit about
why you're doing what you're doing and
then finally we could analyze where our
queries are being shared so that would
allow us to get sort of a context as to
the usage of our tool and so obviously
based on the talk or the title of my
talk I decided to go with analyze where
queries are being shared so I came up
with about with four places that glyph
queries are being shared at Hulu
confluence is our documentation wiki and
so there are a lot of lift queries in
there but they're sort of related to how
the how the tools are supposed to work
so these two filters are supposed to
always be
together or if you want to know you know
what are the top ten shows use this
query something like that and so that's
kind of a different idea than the
real-time shareable queries that I I was
after the wild and so I think while
analyzing the usage of these
documentation queries would be
interesting it wasn't really the purpose
of my talk or of my project there are a
lot of queries that get shared via email
and I think they would probably have a
lot of explanation in context in them
but I'm not going to mine my colleagues
email so that left me with slack and
JIRA I think both of these are a great
place to mine information about our tool
usage and since I mentioned I did this
as part of a one-day data hackathon at
work and the way to get access to our
geo database versus way to get access to
our slack was much easier to do JIRA and
so that's why I started with JIRA that's
what I'll talk about today I do think
that slack would be interesting to use
together with the JIRA data there's
probably a wider audience for people
sharing and in slack and there might be
more context of like back-and-forth does
this what we're supposed to see not sort
of thing so for the rest of the talk I
will talk about how I mining information
about our operational intelligence tool
from JIRA so y'all said that your or
most everyone said they were familiar
with JIRA so I won't spend too much time
on it it's a popular product development
task when it's software suite it's very
well organized and structured as far as
when you look at a ticket and the most
important part is that the fields in the
ticket are searchable and filter bolt
and that's within the JIRA app itself so
you can they want you to be able to find
tickets really easily
so there's basic search and then they
have a jerk query language which allows
you to do more advanced searches and so
for example I made this example ticket
of where how you might see a link to our
lyft query in a ticket so made up this
ticket it's called I notice a problem
with the data so it's a bug obviously
and so I just said you know what I did
and then I put the link actually in the
in the ticket and so there's a lot of
text fields in the JIRA so the
description the summary and the comments
are all text fields but then there's
also details fields which usually can
have different different values in them
and there's people fields date fields
and all these fields can be searchable
within jira so Jared does have these
searchable fields and these allow you to
create filters and based on these
filters you can use JIRA gadgets which
are their visualization tools to create
dashboards and these are really great
dashboards but they are primarily
focused on agile agile measurements like
velocity and burn rate and that sort of
thing since this is primarily a product
development ticketing tool and so they
don't necessarily get a lot of the data
analysis questions that I was interested
in so I
I'll show you like if we're gonna use
JIRA as a data source then we can
consider the values and the text in
there searchable fields and see how
that's related to any kind of outcome
that we want so for example and I'm
gonna use this example for the rest of
the talk or issue types in JIRA so these
are just three issue types um so story
bug and incident and so story is like
you're planning future work like I want
to develop this feature versus bug and
incident are there something wrong
and we need to fix it so you can see
that if I saw a lot of links to glyph
queries in stories I could say Oh glyph
it's being used for a lot of product
feature development versus if I see a
lot of glyph query links and bugs and
incident tickets I can say glyph is
being used to recognize that problems
are happening and glyph is being used to
to say a problem has been resolved and
so those are kind of like different
stages of product development and so
since glyph is giving us real-time data
it might be that there is a lot of bugs
and incidents or we can see how users
are using the app now the Hulu app now
and maybe we can want to see if that
behavior will be changed in the future
and so that would be feature development
and so what I did is I built a flask app
to analyze glyph usage in JIRA tickets
these are the steps I took to uh to
analyze or to build this app I'll skip
down to number five just because that's
out of order and so when I went to try
to figure out how to host this dashboard
on our internal platform at Hulu one of
the examples they gave was a flask app
and so that's why I chose flask and it
was very easy they had a very basic
hello world flask out there and so I
could just take that and then decide to
put my other steps of searching the JIRA
for links to glyph queries extract
relevant data and visualize that data
into the flask app and so the Python
packages that I used for this project
we're four steps one and two I use a
JIRA JIRA library which is a Python
library that allows you to use the JIRA
API it's what out
Atlassian I looked for uses of this JIRA
library in our own Hulu repo and most
everything I found were DevOps related
for automatic creation of tickets and/or
comments there were a few calculator
type scripts related to also p.m. work
like a time to completion or average
time to completion that sort of thing
for visual visualizing I used this old
old library called PI gal it's not
actually maintained anymore again this
was more of a function that I was doing
this in a single day and there were some
really straightforward simple examples
of how to use this and they flask out if
I was going to do this again I would
probably would she was a different
visualization library that was actively
maintained and then I used the flask so
when you're using the zero library to
work with your jer database first you
have to create a jer object which is a
connection to your works JIRA server
that requires you to know the address of
your works server the URL for your work
server and then you need some
authentication if you're just running
this locally you can use your just your
regular JIRA credentials if you're going
to deploy this on to your works internal
hosting platform I would suggest a
different method for authentication and
there's a lot of other methods in their
documentation so just a quick refresher
that this is the my example ticket so
any of these fields are queryable in
JIRA and then they also have some other
fields that are kind of aggregate field
so I can just search text and that will
search the summary description and
comments all together without me having
to search each of those individually
so to get the JIRA tickets that had a
link to glyph queries I use this search
issues method and I just have a jaql
query within that method call and so jql
is just a query language when you're
doing a Bant search on in the JIRA
website that's what you're using and I
recommend testing out the query that you
put in the scripts in the JIRA page
first to make sure you're actually
getting what you intend to get and so
this search issues is going to find all
of the issues that match this query but
it's not going to get the information
out of them it's just going to say these
are the issues that you're interested in
to get the actual information out of
those queries you have to use the issue
method and in the issue method you just
identify the key of the particular issue
and then you identify which field you're
interested in so in this example I'm
just interested in the issue type field
but any of those fields that were on
that JIRA ticket you would add those to
this fields a parameter so here I'm only
getting the issue type out but if I
wanted to get issue type and comments I
would have field equals issue type comma
comments and then for pi gal o it makes
a a chart object and so I set this up to
just make a chart object for each field
that I was looking at so right now
there's only one in here but if I had
three in here it would make me a bar
chart for each of those fields and then
that was really easy to plug in to my to
my flash template and it will render all
of each of those so however many I have
it will just render all of them
and then I could just make a flask up
and route those functions to a single
page and these page contained a table
with links to the JIRA tickets so
luckily the JIRA tickets have a very
easy URL where the name of the ticket is
part of the URL so it's very easy to
make a link for for each of these
tickets and then it also included who
what type of ticket it was and then who
was adding in that glyph query so if
there was I a hulu employee who had put
a cliff query in the description it
would be there or if it was someone in
the comment it would be in the comments
column and then the second part was
these PI gal bar charts with the counts
of each field so I can't show you number
the first part because it has some Hulu
specific information but this is
basically what the second part looks
like where there's it's just really
simple visualization and this is that
issue type and this is for about three
months worth of data and so story and
then test start like the subparts of
stories so it looks like there's about
two thirds for future feature
development and then one third for bugs
what I found was that this is really
time specific so if we if I run this at
a time where there's where we're coming
up to a lot of planning then I'll see
you more play any tickets if I run this
when we have just had planning then I
see more bug tickets just kind of seems
like your expected behavior so these are
all the steps again I never actually got
around to deploying this last gap to our
internal hosting platform that had a lot
to do with the authentication
requirement since I was doing this in a
single day I didn't get my
authentication that was not just my
username and password until
later on now I have another way to do it
so I could deploy it but I just haven't
done that yet but I was able to do all
the other parts so I can run this
locally on my machine whenever I want
sometimes I run it at the beginning of
the month
and then come up with like an award for
the Hulu employee who I use glyphs the
most in their chair tickets over the
past month and then I give them kudos we
have kudos they're like rewards points
you know so that's fun so lessons
learned from doing this project is that
not that many jury tickets include a
glyph query link so when we when I made
a part of our chart of the user name my
name was like way higher than everyone
else's so obviously I had a skewed view
of the world where I thought everybody
was putting these links into their
tickets but that is not the case and
then I'm rich in this before but that
the distribution among issue types or
what project so which team is using it
the most it really depends on the time
range that I looked at as some more
technical lessons learned I learned
about object introspection it didn't
when I first started using the JIRA
library I didn't really understand the
difference between the issue and search
issues and so I wasn't understanding
that I wasn't getting all the data back
with the issues and so I learned about
the inspect and that allowed me to know
that I was not getting all this
information and so I had to figure out
how to do that and then I learned about
the max results
parameter which really increases the
performance of the search issues method
to include this parameter because your
backlog might be really big and so that
helps a lot especially if you're only
interested in recent data open questions
and I still have are about passing data
into different parts of my
application the searching data and
getting data back from Jarrow was
definitely the slowest part of my flask
app and so I wanted to do the query as
few times as possible and I was having a
lot of difficulty managing to pass that
data around to different visualizations
so if anyone is familiar with that
please come talk to me afterwards and
then one other open question I had which
is particularly about JIRA is that Gerry
tickets can be updated and so if I run
this query today and I run this query
tomorrow I can get totally different
results and I know you can search
historical you can make a historical
juror search but that's just something
that you need to keep in mind that if we
run this if we run this same app two
different days we might get two
different results for that reason of
tickets getting updated and so future
developments specifically related to
this glyph usage question I wanted some
output improvements so the tape the
tabular portion of this output dashboard
is really ugly and not sortable or
filterable so I would want to make it
more interactive so that you could do
that and then I would probably just
change to a different visualization
library that was maintained I like to
dig deeper I combined all of the when I
was looking at users I combined all of
them into you regardless of if they had
used it in the description or use them
in the comments and I think it would be
interesting to split them out commenters
versus people who put it in the ticket
and then we have other sources of glyph
data so in addition to seeing where it's
shared I would be able to know what is
the data and filters they were using in
that query when were that when were
those queries viewed and
that information I think would be
interesting to add on and in mind slack
I think combining the JIRA information
with slack information could be even
more powerful there's problems like I
said slack has a wider audience like for
GRA just have to know you have to be
tagged or signed or watching and that
ticket to see it versus in slack I can
just post it in a slack channel and then
anybody in that slack channel can can
click on and see that ticket and there
might be more discussion around what is
actually going on in the glyph query and
slack as well I think there's lots of
other analyses that could be done with
JIRA data just given a couple of
examples here I think that it would be
very interesting to see if there was
some sort of relationship between
comment sentiment and resolution time or
if there's a relationship between
mention of any of our other internal
tools like QA tools or anything like
that with resolution time so is there
any sort of process that is done at
least or outlined on the ticket that
leads to a quicker resolution time there
are a few alternatives to mining your
own data out of JIRA there's a JIRA or a
tableau JIRA connector so if you're
really good at tableau and you can
import your JIRA into tableau and make
dashboards there and then there are
these JIRA gadgets that exist and so if
one of those is going to give you the
information that you're interested in
then that makes it even easier and so
now it's your turn hopefully now you
guys feel empowered to go out and mine
your own personal or your own employers
JIRA databases for mention of your app
or whatever you're interested in and now
you know how you can do that in Python
so thank you so much
[Applause]
yes yeah so that I think it's a that's a
really good question and I think that is
what I would have liked to do I think
that it didn't my idea of mining data
from JIRA about glyph usage didn't gain
as much traction as I was hoping
yes oh okay
yeah so in the ticket it has like your
ID of your project so with my project
it's called data analysis then therefore
my my projects idea is probably like da
or something like that and then each of
those you'll have like a da to get one
and da take it to and that sort of thing
but there is an ID for each comments
like there's a comment ID so I think
there's an ID for most of these events
to get at them specifically yes
so unfortunately and my work repo which
is not public there the JIRA library has
a lot of documentation on it and some
examples there so yeah yes great so in
that three months worth of data there
was like 100 tickets that had a link to
my query tool but like how many were
researching through I have no idea there
is a lot of projects going on so there's
a lot
yes what am i working on at hula what
I'm excited about
I think just in general I I really like
working with this tool I kind of help
help our engineers or our product teams
use a tool to get to understand the data
to make their product decisions so I
think that's one of my favorite things
about my job is to sort of help people
get data to make the decisions that
they're trying to make instead of just
making decisions so but and I do that
with this tool and then I also do that
with some of the data that's not
available in the tool so it's pretty fun
to be able to support the other teams by
giving them niether so as far as what
and our data or yeah so we use so my
team is data analysts and we use Python
tableau a lot of press now and hive and
did I'm not sure what the data science
team is is I think they use a similar
set of tools will obviously not tableau
and but they similar set of tools this
is in Python 3
okay thank you
[Applause]